yeah you're right they're right there
signer X with a full day ere all six -
all six two inches calls himself an
ectomorph but the kids got the kid I'm
not mad at his muscle we on you're on
dude I don't know if there's no cameras
right now Jesus - no right from the bike
well see what our testosterone spiked
because because Simon watch me
manipulate manipulate Brendan in the
hallway why got underhooks I went hips
I went head how dare you embarrass me in
front of feel my yeah it was right in
the hallway in front of let me yeah I
just saw Theo down the hall grew who we
all agree is the greatest human being on
the planet Earth
Anton very - if he was a stock I'd
invest in - thank you but I don't know
if that's an option it's a very good way
to put it you know they used to actually
have it's a great compliment to a
comedian no I tell him that all the time
he's he makes me feel some love in my
heart that not too many comedians no
offense yeah I'd love a like a Care Bear
remember the Care Bear yes the lowest
Lauer's your heart right while you guys
are like getting low and fighting he's
loving and hugging you already never
seen one like do like oh he's like that
guy
well he'll also the way he was raised
and Brennan is also unique because what
if you notice when I was attacking him
what did he do he climbed up a clamp I
did not but I thought that was his
defense because he doesn't like law
policy doesn't like his conserving his
energy for no he doesn't like anybody
who is like a talented guy like yourself
an artist he doesn't want anybody to
know what a brute he actually is so for
him he hates that he is a giant and that
he can actually kill it I didn't realize
how big you were until now I met in
person and then the big man 26:42 17250
about not about 240 right oh really
about 240 for lightweight just more nos
244 about 250 it went okay to 44 out of
questions mm college for you got it 244
burn calories which according to his
calories of [ __ ] will get in that
Lane yeah well good calories bad
calories but our boy over here there's
no
brennon they're all strong and then
there's Brendon oh you like natural so
did you work for it away what's your
genetic what are you made out of what's
your genetic diversity have you done
23andme we I have not really I think
what you are no my parents say I'm
Italian German and English the jerk
maybe it's the German in there that
sounds like it's instance fourth grade
but I know guys who trained with him who
are like heavyweights and UFC and stuff
like that they all go like Cody Donovan
those guys Lauren Lando they go well
there's strong and then there's Brendan
so in other words well so I'll explain
so Brendan will take about 550 I don't
know if you know if that's 550 on a
crossbar go head pounds right yeah and
then he'll do ten reps you let that tail
head lift and then you'll do that
then ten sets of that or if you want
them do a Turkish getup he can put he'll
take 155 pounds on a straight dumbbell
right lie down and stand up with it oh I
the one-handed yeah or how about it do
you want him to carry a hundred pounds
in each hand please carry would you
he'll do that for he'll do that for five
minutes you mean carry your groceries
around Venice that helps the ton doesn't
help too much of my in my comedy game
now okay now do you're retired as a
fighter is that correct correct do you
still do it now you're just trained for
a hobby just to get your guy I'll hit
mitts and then I do you don't get hit
anymore you got to protect the melon
right you've got the permanent ear that
yeah that's the first thing you see if
you see those ears you goes like the way
they've lot more than most humans will
see the cauliflowers not good you know
it man guys go away from it I go away
from it now like I never get hit in the
head I'll hit mitts right three four
times a week or not see I'm balls deep
in this peloton bike man in the what
mike pelton bike what's that it's like
junior advertisement coming on I promise
my okay oh it's a personal luxury
it's just something yeah I mean they
started shown before it's like a what
would you call like a spin bike it's a
really so you can you can put the
intervals okay so like you can put how
hard you want it and I've seen those
before use like a thousand different
classes on demand
I see so you just get on there and those
I do like spinner seriously this is
mostly cardiologists this is cardio this
is cardio okay that's my car I'm old
school I jump rope the three minute
round
jump rope push-ups in between as long as
I get my five three-minute rounds in and
100 pushups in that's my minimal for the
day anything else is extra yeah that's
just what I could do on the road with
jump rope bring the jump rope it's easy
and I think we haven't style I see I
think that prison sounds better because
people want to they want to hire all
these crazy trainers and their diets
right all it all leads back to one thing
what's that you're the old school stuff
works man yeah who says who wants to
reinvent it this thing's the most
humbling thing you I think oxime so
humbling that once I tried that I its to
make you more humble I was humbled by
all the black brown jiu-jitsu I can't
wait to tell you guys my story about
jiu-jitsu can we just get into that okay
so i about I'd say well over ten years
ago I was introduced to henna and heat
on Gracie through evidence of dilated
peoples he's a rapper a great guy friend
of mine he's like Yoshi come train with
these guys I lived in Hollywood's our
drive each way did you meet him from an
elder brother evidence or header and he
Don evidence no from what other brother
yeah they're just best friends no
brothers go but anyway you say henna and
here on without yeah the are is there's
a beautiful role to the are thank you I
owe that he that's what he's coming up
from Brazil no I hear a henna with his
teacher headers might still this day my
head juicy coach carry on with your
story okay yeah okay so yes so I
approached it with great humility as the
only martial arts I've ever done in my
life was judo as a little kid so I'm
like let me just try this and see let me
get a routine going I need some
structure in my life right so I go train
an hour drive each way once a week for
about a year and as I'm about to get my
blue belt I have my three stripes and
I'm about to get my blue belt and this
is al Bundy's class you know Ned O'Neill
and I don't see some real legit guys
this is before they built their super
academies as years ago and for whatever
reason this is one of the things also in
this book that I I'm so different than
then abri and a lot I have an attention
span of a billy goat so what happens is
I'll get super into something for a year
and then I'm [ __ ] over it really
alright
that's just like other than that oh look
a bird you know and then I don't do
wrong with
so I'm owning the day I'm owning the
truth but it's so what happens is I just
get bored or something so I was like
[ __ ] this Drive and I'm not a fighter I
look in the mirror I know I'm not a
fighter I'm more of a kid okay kiss so
I'm kids a kid beautiful blue eyes thank
you they're actually technically green
but we'll let you slice okay actually
technically hazel but we don't need this
is not for eyes porcelain skin
Roman Roman nose Roman nose you look
Italian
I feel Italian bullheaded Brian you
thought you're good-looking not easy
Calvin Klein Tommy Hilfiger model yeah
look at me was that true you know hey
but just yeah shut your mouth and I'm
about Beauty around yeah this is my girl
I'm basically I'm like almost triple
threat you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
amazing personality humble yeah and I
know how to work that you know the dick
a little I got angles so it's like five
quintuple now you give me five I don't
we'll get into the hair let me finish my
fight stories like this is your fun no
no no I apologize
oh alright so basically I trained for
your and iadd out and I know that's an
excuse and everyone has ADHD of some
sort but whatever I stopped doing it and
I go I just bored with it so you know
I'm not good I'm just not good at it I
realize I drink a while it's just not my
thing and I'm constantly getting worked
by some kid at my age so I put it once a
week what true okay so a few years later
I go let me try a local class so I go to
Beverly Hills Jiu Jitsu through my buddy
Scott econ brings me there he's a little
beast I don't know if you know Scotty
but he's a little animal teri he could
rip a phone book in half for real he's a
little animal strong a little [ __ ]
short very very strong those the guys
yeah one thing I learned in jiu-jitsu
class yes he's our Hawaii five-o his dad
oh oh yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] we dig
in did Yugi he doesn't do much weaker
he's not Twitter he does doesn't smoke
weed but count ographers yeah he's very
good and a band he's a [ __ ] tough
[ __ ] dude and anyway so he
brought me in the class and I'm doing it
for a couple of months and one day I
come to class
and nobody else shows up out of a
10-person class just me and this black
monster from Texas that had muy Thai
shorts on with all these patches that
he'd won tournaments oh and the teacher
I forget his name the Brazilian guy
Beverly Hills jiu-jitsu I can't America
yes Marco he goes you guys just roll at
it and he goes like to the office
this guy proceeds to beat the [ __ ] out
of me on a level of well not beat me up
but you know constantly like squash and
at one point he was just beating my ass
and at one point he's sitting on my face
and I'm smelling his [ __ ] oh boy look
at deep deep Dee Dee Musk a deep burlap
[ __ ] iodine meets blood and [ __ ] and
there was a lot going on yeah and as I'm
sure as he's sitting on my face with my
arm behind my back and I said to myself
I'm paying money for this ever went back
again except when Kron had me come roll
at his class for fun once just to see
what I had a similar experience where I
was [ __ ] really in digital wrestler
before that loved it I'm very athletic
as you can do yeah yeah I can see that
I'll control your body I understand
everything about the body right and and
I I'm watching and the teachers going
you guys are putting your hand here I
want you to it's got to be palm palm to
ceiling when you come low look how I
grabbed the collar and I went I don't
care anymore
right that's it you're out palm to
collar was the fire I go I don't find
out I'm out I don't about when I was
like in the mid like going on my last
run in the UFC bragging me and Brian
Brian I brought Brian with me to my last
training car so went with me every what
year is this I'm painting the pictures
I'm 14 yeah
- I'm 14 I've recently I'm 15 14 14 14
November 2004 okay look so Brian is
Brian Brian's going to camp with me and
we're driving the highway and he goes
how much do you think you do a song I
don't know but I mean this options how
much you want when you keep those you do
a comedy at this point now you're gonna
find the kid in five kid lives and
and the podcast starting things go yeah
well what happened was things are
starting to pick up and not like that he
was getting recognized more than anybody
else because you big brown yeah so - so
2014 yet so November so me and Brian
drive around and he goes and I'm beat up
I'm worn out get done sparring at in
gardena that black house these monsters
leo DOE and this giant Jack maze and
bring us how much like anything induce
I'll know I don't know man but I want
the MD Jitsu for the rest of my life in
bring us oh you're not I went broke take
it easy no you're not
I don't wait yeah dude I don't like you
in punch of face while I love just my
passion right I said I love just
assuming humble he'll [ __ ] everyone if I
get yes so yes you so Brian is no you're
not and I was like I'm on a dick
so wait wow you know you're not because
like for me I got still train with
header on Saturday mornings every now
felt class be racist but here's what I
said here's what I said here's what I
said no you're not because I knew that
the the game he was playing which is
sparring we are striking getting hit in
the head the fear just that nightmare
and I'll tell you why and all the
training jiu-jitsu was like a like a
real almost like a release it was like
where he could go and just roll and no
he's not gonna get concussed at least
but you're then you're saying what your
point is that you're saying you're
saying no you won't do jujitsu anymore
but I thought that's what I hadn't seen
him I had seen him roll with the best in
the world and do very well uh-huh better
than are going into details okay I and
he's way too humble for his own good
play goes a nod this guy's way better
and I was like I was watching I go mmm
you're better actually
so so I knew that he had reached as far
as he would I know him and I knew where
his brain was going which was more
toward the artistic side right and and
just to be more in the business of
expressions okay go on it was just I was
you know because for me to send traffic
same thing we do in its may see an hour
drive there our class shower about
hour and a half ninety minutes use every
day then I will commit for hours you to
help me on stage anymore just you don't
help my college is not in the ecosystem
and I'm sorry okay so I still love it
still bad news autumn cetera now can I
pick a nice [ __ ] or not right can I
shift gears yeah I okay again let me
preface this by stating I am NOT a tough
guy nor do I believe I'm a tough guy but
I used the little training that I got
from my one year combined of jujitsu to
be a little more it's more I got I got
yeah yeah I got in a fight in Australia
it's a great story if I may how long
does this this was uh six seven years
ago what's with we're at no Sydney okay
so I I do a comedy music act that I take
on the road called Dirt Nasty where I
perform live at comedy clubs and music
venues and I do half songs have stand-up
improv with the audience so I kind of
have the life of a comic so I kind
understand what you guys the life on the
road what it's like you know but I do
music gigs but it becomes this comedy
hybrid anyway so I'm on the road and I
go to Australia where I have a pretty
good following out there and I land and
I realize the tour manager booked me the
night that I landed which has you know
if you've flown to across the times I
was the worst and I landed at 5 a.m. and
I look at my watch I'm like oh you gotta
be kidding me I gotta perform tonight
dude all day long I was the long as they
espressos trying to stay awake I can't
believe my shows at like 1:00 a.m. I'm
not a Napper so I can't nap cuz then
everyone's like dude if you take a nap
you're really gonna be [ __ ] you stay
up so I pushed through and I couldn't
have written this any better I get on
stage in Sydney at this club that had
recently had a lot of attention because
I guess the security had stomped a dude
out to death okay they killed a guy in
there so there was already a lot of
eyeballs on this club in the cross it's
called I think the neighbor is called
the cross anyway so I jump on stage and
immediately a guy jumps on stage grabs
the mic out of my hand
yells Australia and punches me in the
face with the mic in his hand and the
microphone made that noise like
it was amazing so listen this is just a
beginning so I'm like well welcome right
so he punches me in the face we you know
when you hold a roll of quarters any
worse so so he punches me and I I was
savvy enough to turn my face with the
punch so as he punches me my face turns
directly at my DJ I see him right there
and I just see him like oh [ __ ] and I
hit to this day he says I've never seen
you have that look in your eyes of like
you're a pretty peaceful nice dude you
had a fire in your eyes and I
instinctively looked back at the dude
and we run about as high as this like it
may be foot and a half off the ground
right in this stage and I grabbed the
dude and it just just it all kicked in
like without thinking I grabbed the dude
by his t-shirt because we did t-shirt
training too with henna and he done yeah
grab the t-shirt did the turn right turn
tripped fell on top of them off the
stage ground-and-pound as I'm doing it I
remember thinking I can't believe how
easy that was and I'm beating this
dude's ass and I'm just lighting them up
and secured and a circle forms around us
and they're going to nasty nah Steve the
character I passed was a great it was
the crowds like supporting me I was like
high school they form a circle around
junior exactly and I'm beating them up
and at least my version of beating up I
didn't really get hurt but I was
technically like on a point system I won
okay so I'm hitting November thinking
like and security grabs me off they go
Oh mate we didn't think you had in you
[ __ ] great form yeah yeah so I'm like
holy [ __ ] they kicked the dude I don't
know I'll bring that dude back I want to
buy him a beer back in because honestly
I couldn't have planned it any better
it's like okay I'm gonna jump on stage
you're gonna grab the mic you're gonna
yell Australia you're gonna punch me
then let me beat you up in front of that
but your adrenaline was like this wow
[ __ ] sleep I couldn't sleep that night
was the because it actually no I'm wrong
I could sleep that night I slept better
that night because it felt so good to
fight somebody on a primal level I got
it out I wasn't hitting a bag it was
[ __ ] amazing so the dude comes they
so I try to buy him a drink and bring
them back in so they're later
find out the next day I tweet out does
anybody have footage of me fighting that
guy in Australia I have to see what that
looked like you know and immediately the
promoters texted me and said take that
[ __ ] down right now we just had
someone die in the club take that [ __ ]
down right away we have a problem so I
deleted it I land in Adelaide and when I
land in Adelaide I see this monster guy
at the airport in a suit and he's just
you could tell he's a fighter guy I'm
like what what's going on they're like
oh well your security might what heard
you a real scrapper and I'm like dude
I'm the least scrapper ever all of a
sudden they think I'm like a loose
cannon out there so I so on this tour I
had this reputation oh he'll be a badass
like I'm the biggest [ __ ] I'm the guy
who always stopped a fireman so it was
funny for like a week to be a badass
like that people look at you like I'll
use [ __ ] crazy can I tell you how to
tell my dude it was the can I say that's
a great story
97 story I want you sure was so I go
next time you tell that story all you
got to do is just go and I was always
well mom and they were like bit nasty
dad nasty and I want you to pause and go
and I killed him yeah I noticed what you
were just grounding a pounding you're
good you had very true about you
realizing it you were turning the wrists
perfectly no he's gonna get mad but I
went I went a rounds yes eight rounds
when 80 rounds it was mitts or with a
man and I spotted Mitt Romney row this
way fast
thank you I lit up a little bit my head
hurts and also you were getting hit
you're sparring for inspire I wasn't
heavier I was and and I got I got tagged
up a little bit okay you get to protect
that melon now that you have 13 episodes
so and also this area hurts my neck
yeah but this yeah well it may have you
may ask how old are you
I'm 51 oh you look you look great how
are you sir I'm 43 but have the body of
a 42 year old I know there's things we
do understand you know just me
moved to Venice Venice I just sold my
house in Laurel Canyon I was telling
them in the lovely elevator system you
have in the building that we all right
it's good it's good elevator I just sold
my house in Laurel Canyon and I got a
little apartment by the [ __ ] beach
and I'm so much happier I got rid of
eighty percent of my [ __ ] I got rid of
my second car I had a 68 Buick I had all
this [ __ ] all these clothes I got rid of
everything
simplified holy Barbie though yeah bro
is there room to park Marv you guys ever
know there was outdoor learning I got it
three days ago and I got to go get a
propane because I'm going to San Diego
maybe even Mexico tomorrow so he's got
to fill up the propane so I just are you
primarily a musician sigh okay so I
guess I'm a ya know so check it out man
here's the deal I didn't know what to
call myself until I recently did this
thing for for vice where they simply
said entertainer that's what I am
correct I'm an entertainer but oddly
whether it's my phone and I'm doing a
silly video for my fans or it's a song
or it's a movie or a TV show or you know
I just did me in swartz and just did a
web series for Comedy Central I just
like to make people ask me what I do
what do you do I'm in the business of
original self-expression oh god the
worst laughter your theater actor that's
if that's why that's myself how about
using Costa Rica it's game story and I
just he goes bro you're you guys are
finally kids huge in Costa Rica it's
just some like you know local sitting on
the rock other kid he goes finally get
fan she's like I don't like mean comedy
but that was almost mean because they
were just like looking at me like I'm
saying alien robot come the maldehyde
situations all years are huge she had no
idea so after that whole story the point
is don't [ __ ] with me okay dudes as you
can see like I don't think you realize I
will literally lunge across this your
Spyder do i what to do with that length
of like like you could train all you
want and I know you have wrestling
behind oh you're most comfortable
wrestling your jab you might get under
there but you don't realize you're some
elbows i dude like seriously you will be
I will Swiss both you guys up like
you'll be folding over you questioning
your exist Matt Brown elbows dude you
will fold up like a table and question
you what would you like a question for a
sign now you you're in that group was it
three local yes three loco yeah yeah
right you guys are actually baking will
be behind bring up your way up yeah
three look let me get [ __ ] track that
Diplo yeah also its riffraff yeah Andy
Milonakis Diplo produced it yeah yeah
and some other producers as well still
single man I'm dating a girl and we're
figuring it out because I'm in a
long-distance relationship and you know
in your life you put up some numbers
yeah sure
I feel like all former MTV VJs have
herpes now that's just that for me I
somehow have avoided it maybe Carson de
personnes seem likes to dress I've
avoided herpes on my lips you know but
you get out you get you have an immunity
apparently yeah it's hard to get it I
guess apparently yeah when you have it
on your in your mouth it's harder to get
it on your butt you have herpes of the
mouth yeah I had an ex-girlfriend you
don't mask its dimplex one
ex-girlfriend sit me down many years ago
and she's a outfield remain nameless
she's an actress she sat me down as
dating her and she says to me I got to
tell you something she lived in Orange
County I live in Hollywood she's like I
got to drive up and tell you I'm like
[ __ ] here we go drives up pregnant
yeah something it drives her telling she
goes I have herpes okay should I go
where up or down she goes both I go so
what do we do we wear a condom we don't
kit like we do we wait for a breakout
like I don't know what to do we went to
the doctor together and the doctor said
it's quite possible that you know it
lives in every one and only surfaces in
some people so you may never get it even
if you do so I dated her free he never
had an ever knock I would never got it
so I don't know you like think I'm what
you call superhuman III better to I'm
better than you laugh at any kind of
pathogen for me this is what kind of a
scumbag
[ __ ] up I am I've been in three
situations where girls have been like to
see no I have herpes in high and I don't
have condoms and it was I was younger
man and I was like well Donna dice we'll
figure it out I'm not gonna not have so
had a buddy and you you'll have a but
you know this guy in this this girl came
in and I was like oh my god what is her
deal he's like bro I'm like really goes
so close we were going to the other
night she came over finally and she's
like a 10 like just the hottest game
you've ever seen you know she came over
and I was so fired up and she goes I
have a flare-up of her oh wow and I go
oh this is on us so yeah yeah that's so
what'd you do he goes nothing you know
oh she's gonna flare up you might want
to be careful today show this I think
the one you'd want to see is probably
neat neato might be this the one we are
farmers in my our farmers is the Diplo
one I don't know yeah maybe you want a
big time it was big time I'll tell you
the story after this I'm a big fan he's
great he's great I'll get him on the
podcast uh he's a trip
Buechele all three of you on yeah that'd
be great well there's a good segue out
on this I'll tell you about
do you guys watch the whole video or is
this we I'd be considered to the viewer
or listening go build it here we on
camera right here yeah and then they'll
be able to see the video in the shuttle
other watchin the magic she's a
beautiful she's a beautiful girl and II
predominately does this stuff now he
does a lot of twitch which is that
extremely or matte that's his new
challenge guy yeah yes holes like the 42
years yes use it but he's like the first
Internet guy
[Music]
oh great voice thanks it's a definitely
character really
I wouldn't say singer watch a little
riff and then yeah then we'll stop who's
that yep big off that vh1 show and I
watched it to tell you the whole riff
raff story riff raff like makes a living
oh yeah I've never seen any and II love
the hood love funny hood hall-pass like
the inner cities really a funny [ __ ]
so quickly to rewind a little bit the
story behind this is that well first of
all let me say that we just shot a pilot
for TBS three local pilot with todd
phillips producing he's the [ __ ] best
yeah so he jumped onboard as a friend of
mine to just throw his name on there to
help push it through you know very very
nice of him considering he doesn't need
to do that yeah especially television so
he jumped on board as EP and he just
kind of oversees the project so we're
waiting to see if we get picked up so
fingers crossed there'll be a three BS
show you know how this [ __ ] goes hurry
up and wait it's been a year and a half
who shot it way I'm [ __ ] out the
[ __ ] lottery
so I'm seasoned enough to know to not
get too attached the result of the
emotion side of it cannot be yeah who
did the game so going back a little bit
riff-raff was on a show that you just
mentioned called G's to gents which was
a show where they took dudes from the
hood and tried to make them gentlemen
teach them how to have etiquette not be
so ghetto and like you know brilliant
show
grave mistake of kicking riffraff off
the first episode correct he was the
show they kicked they're like we can't
save you but it's like duh that's what's
interesting at the host personality was
the star of the show could this person
grow up he grew up in Houston and he's
just very he's this literally like neon
braids and gold teeth he's he lives he I
remember I first met him I was like is
this dude for real it was an act so so
basically long story short there's a
video if anyone out there is a fan of
riffraff and they want to see how this
happened I have a video on YouTube
called a day with riffraff part 1 and
you see me and Andy pick him up at the
motel he was staying at shooting the G's
to gents reunion and I went to pick him
up you see the moment we shook his hand
and met him cut to Diplo record deal TBS
show at Todd Phillips lay the whole
thing was over
it looks cool as [ __ ] though he's yeah
he's got a great look he's like a
good-looking my thing is he's obviously
it's he's off state a little bit of hood
but I thought he brings huge that's why
my keys that's what my [ __ ] that dude it
feels like I'm gangster this and guns he
never talks about being tough and he's
always fun to personalize videos are
Clint really funny walking he's getting
all big yeah funny
yeah he's a funny [ __ ] do that he
falleth that that's a that's a lot of
creativity right there's my dude he's
just like at first glance people like
what is this guy and then you really dig
in and you're like too easy kind of a
cool exactly absolutely right he would
cool so anyway he we became friends a
day with riffraff part one you see the
moment we met and the rest just kind of
happened naturally we all recorded music
and you know years later TB we shot a
Christmas special for TBS two
Christmases ago and they just said these
guys need a show so we just shot a pilot
but anyway riff and Andy are my boys and
then there's the other comin to them
Andy where does he come in the house
Andy come into this whole circuit well
he and I have really close friends and
we went along we found Alchemist showed
me riff raff on YouTube years ago and in
one of his riff Raff's videos he goes
y'all think I'm a joke call me on the
phone
seven six out 8:07 whatever his number
was I called the number any answers to
phone and me and him there's all on the
video David riff raff he answers the
phone and he's like more like this is
this is Dirt Nasty and Andy Milonakis
like I quit [ __ ] with me man based in
Houston at this point
really yes we'd love to meet you we're
big fans like [ __ ] you thought was a
joke anyway we really went met him
became friends and I think the guy
co-sign him since day one he's a [ __ ]
brilliant guy
now he's real he's doing some work yeah
yeah he's gone bulking like season
whatever you know and he's [ __ ] he's
but some muscle he decided to get rough
and he went and did it you know yeah he
want to get his real skinny only get
super buff nights back to it kind of
like to drop like 20 pounds you would he
would constantly be on tour and he comes
to be in big name shows meals and just
be like Panda Express all this like he's
just trying to get big right yeah he's
just going for this wall you know anyway
great funny dude know that anytime I
steroids yeah a lot of Purcell funny you
saw how he's just getting jackets
hilarious but he's all the way out
people at first like why are you [ __ ]
with this clown like no trust me the
guy's hilarious
anyway it's cool to see him have done so
well because I saw it from the beginning
look at the difference in arms on there
he's really funny dude you'll see some
delicious so yeah so that's one of my
music projects I have another one with
this guy named Mickey Avalon who I
believe your boy Eddie Bravo produces
music isn't that right he went to
Mickey's house the other day to play him
some beats and Ikey didn't know who
Eddie was and like how that would be a
good look for him and laugh but you know
why not work together so he's like I
have no idea I'm like no that's like
Rogen's boy the guy's classic is a
jujitsu thing he's like you should work
with him why not so now I think they're
gonna be works again so Miki Avalon is
my other music group that I do when I
don't do it alone
so anyway it's that's one of my cuz that
one of my claims like it was my comedy
music act I take on the road so it's
cool yeah yeah it's definitely fun
because that like again like it's I
lived that life of a comedian man I go I
show up in a town I put some smiles on
some faces Rock a few songs keep it
moving and you're in the trenches you're
in you're in you know I just did a
30-city tour over two months Jesus I
know at 43 years old I've learned to
split it up like I go on the road for 12
days come home for a week hit the road
for 10 days come home no kids no kids
yeah
okay you took it yeah you do - yeah okay
I'm gonna have those things one day I
just there's the the key factor that I
haven't I need the woman yes you said
you know the problem is that sometimes
you're attracted to UM you're attracted
to the life certain type of woman yes
and then there are the women that you
trust that will raise her kids and see
her we could go down this road oh damn
this is this is this is the case I can
tell just by how I can tell by your
forward tilt by your imagination by the
way you talk about the forward we write
that down yes yeah the question mark
body needs to beat you you I know you
pull you pull those kind of the kind of
girls that are Ferraris delicious
Ferraris - toys whatever you want to
call it Jesus that's degrees by a nice
way to Ferrari and and I think though if
you want children's sometimes you've got
a transition to Alexis something that's
sensible that's Benny that's not grief
but Friday makes a sedan as well you can
find something you can you can't settle
brother um you guys familiar with the
Madonna [ __ ] complex we okay no I'm not
so Madonna Horvath mean I want a Madonna
I want Madonna Madonna is essentially
the Italian for mother Mary so it's pure
as mother Mary of Jesus's mother okay so
I wanted you on a Nicki Minaj mama I
know but I want no it's the Madonna
[ __ ] complex it's Madonna / I want I
want Madonna out in the world and I want
a [ __ ] in the bed you want a freak in
the sheets basically also it to add to
that a little bit I think the Madonna
[ __ ] complex is also there could be
comes a point here's my pattern is I'm
dating a girl the sex is amazing it's
new it's fresh it's fun it's like
everything's like butterflies and
unicorns and then there comes a point
where you they become your mother sister
daughter and you want to protect them
from being a [ __ ] so no then the sex
suffers and all of a sudden there
becomes this weird thing this shift that
happens for me at least anyway and
that's
therein lies the canary though we've
been together for about eight months
yeah and we just actually at the talk
the other day she lives in London
she ain't moved in LA I live in LA I
ain't moving the line what are we doing
what are we doing so we're just kind of
put it on a hunt yeah exactly and she's
I just finally met like a really funny
sweet Canadian girl that
except in the morning and is just nice
and pleasant and just a total sweet yet
the other day you want to be with
somebody like nice and and fun for me
you know they could be beautiful you
just you 99% of the times hanging out
with them you want to you're gonna
become best friends no exactly so this
girl I finally met my best partner about
other people whatever well anyway so so
we're trying to figure it out but yeah
yeah it's tricky it's tricky long
distance things I mean [ __ ] I live in
Venice the girl in downtown LA is a long
distance relationship
now here enough so [ __ ] flying 13,000
miles away [ __ ] difficult to find
line because you can live that life
where you're constantly in town to town
hooking up with those girls and doing
that but I just feel like that wrote
does not end well the other friends were
like that I did that and it was it's fun
for a while but you at the end I'm also
here's the thing too I'm at this age and
this point in my life where I have the
dreaded conscience like I don't actually
feel bad where I used to be like
reckless with girls hearts and I
genuinely didn't give a [ __ ] about how I
was acting are the repercussions of my
actions as you get old and you get older
and all of a sudden you don't want to be
a piece of [ __ ] leave the wake of yeah
and it's just you know it is and and and
that's I struggle with that lately
because not giving a [ __ ] really works
yeah with a lot of things especially in
this business yeah you walk in a room
you don't get when you walk in audition
and you care too much they see that all
over you the infinite turn JJ Leno on
the Centaurs of Garry Shandling did you
see it oh yeah a [ __ ] amazed don't
make this business your mistress or the
business should be your mistress don't
make it it should be your side don't get
a show business if you want to be happy
it's a famous old saying it'll break
your heart dude but that one time you
get that good news it's funny actually
man you got to be able to take like you
gotta be able to take the nose and
there's a lot of nose if you can't take
rejection it is personal sometimes
because you invest yourself as a
producer writer creator and maybe it's
not for you these acts I'm saying some
people can't handle the I always say if
you're gonna you're gonna have a but
you're gonna [ __ ] your knees up right if
you plan this business you're it you're
gonna deal with a lot of disappointment
don't be surprised I like the NFL
comparison because when people always
asked me like I've had moderate success
but in this business moderate success is
is
success you know if you work enough now
to pay the bills I think I think 90% of
sag or more makes under 20 grand a year
or something alarm or Center like inner
to snow living like I'm so blessed like
I've [ __ ] done studio films and
Network shows and like dude it's all but
I've got a taste of everything and it's
like most people never even get any of
that so I've been extremely fortunate
and and I don't even work that much but
I was used I used to comparison I say
it's like I'm in the NFL and I'm on the
field so I'm in the game I'm just not
the guy at the end the game that the
cameras are running up interviewing me
after but I'm playing ball I'm there and
up so I'm I'm in the game and I'm on the
field you know I might not be starting I
get a little Petey but just being on the
fields enough for me right it's enough I
don't need to be because here's the
thing and in Hollywood you're driving
down the street and you could look up at
a billboard and see your peers and be
like man why am I not working as much as
them and trust me they're calling their
agent going why mine it's never enough
I heard that talking in somebody said
something really great like that I
camera you're never gonna be fulfilled
because it says know what everybody has
a level like denzel's mad he's not
directing rosemarys not Denzel I just
goes you can just go all the way down
I'm saying so I'm finally understanding
starting to understand that and and
actually listening to your podcast the
other day about you when you're talking
about when you got your 13 episodes
picked up congratulations that's the
best news ever amazing because
especially because what I think was like
a couple years ago you had the spin-off
for a brief a year ago a year ago and
then it got ripped like I've had that
one happened where I he's the first guy
I call dude that way I felt for you
because I felt really bad but for me I'd
be good on the chin and I remember one
time I booked a pilot for WB back in the
day that that it was a Steve Martin
pilot there was the Mindy and Brenda
show Mindy Mindy's the girl who's the
Indian actress who's in everything now
the AH it was her first show that Steve
Martin saw play they did so I got hooked
on there was a sitcom live audience I
said that's a big big deal right you
wanted badly so my agent at UTA calls me
up he goes congrats the pilots picked up
I go pop the bottle picked up like I
could go celebrate goes go celebrate bro
in the air Steve Martin's flying to New
York for the up front they change their
mind
he turns the plane around midair and
comes back I'm out celebrating I'm not
celebrating the show's picked up 3900
yeah it's happened to me
dude you're did that same thing because
I even knew to say for sure like pop the
champagne and then I learned oh don't
celebrate until you're not sad and then
don't even celebrate then after the
pilot would you hired you can get fired
and every what did I do
I just just I learned and bad lived and
kept going to happen to me well not only
that happened to me but I've also seen
plenty of times where at the table read
the person gets fired oh I've seen that
I've seen that so you got me till
they're not good they just are just not
right for the parts you know we made a
mistake we're gonna go with this other
person but you have to understand when
you get a pilot just getting it that's
another you that's a win yeah that's a
victory it's you want it so badly and
then you just go you smell blood yeah it
goes I won't be out of work for the next
year if it doesn't go I'll be out of
woman to max but here's the thing even
if you let's say you're a new actor and
you get your you're on a sitcom you get
your 30 naps though it's that you didn't
make my favorite is young but you
created the character so there's a
different situation but my favorite is
but not my favorite but when I get I've
been doing this so long that when I do a
TV show and any pilot I've ever done any
father ever done it's always the younger
actors who are so excited I get it cuz I
was oh and they're like yeah then they
they're making plans and they know
what's gonna go but of course the court
of course it is and of course I know
it's not gonna go of course I know that
it's I know that it's that that where
it's you 100% not gonna go because of a
thousand things especially because I can
see how this network watch this this is
when you really know it's not the
network is so happy they're flipping
yeah they're [ __ ] they're like
already making plans they literally are
saying did you hear that I don't know if
you are but they are there so they they
can't believe it they're told in I go oh
we're dead oh we're dead okay how about
this and I remember I was doing this
show on The WB back in like 2000 it was
Amanda Bynes show called what I like
about you with Jennie Garth who was
America's Sweetheart from 902 100 and I
was like the boyfriend of Jennie Garth
slash older brother of Amanda Bynes
and so I'm on The WB at the Warner
Brothers lot [ __ ] making amazing
money I'm so young and cocky yeah I'd
take it for granted so much I remember
her after like season two I got a call
from the head writer visiting my family
on the East Coast and I get a calling
they like hey Simon so we just want to
let you know like if you notice you're
gonna be written in these episodes this
season less and less don't worry we're
not writing you off the show and of
course I took it as we're writing you
off the show question why the [ __ ] else
would you be telling me that's right and
I just remember thing at that but okay
just at least you're right at least
you're still on the show for another you
know 12 up to 13 episodes whatever track
nine it was a back nine yeah it was a
back nine order so I remember thinking
[ __ ] and then learning my [ __ ] like okay
well you got 21 episodes on that's
[ __ ] amazing like like like that's
very difficult in and this was eight 17
years ago like oh 2000 2001 something
like that anyway that's back when they
were making a lot of sitcoms a sitcom by
the way is the best gig in Hollywood
you're in your pajamas all week
you know let's put on hair and makeup
till Friday night it's a live play that
you could [ __ ] up it's cut that's right
get the excitement of like that's right
perform well sign fell it's the brazier
all those shows friends it's a you come
in on a Monday you do a table read
you'll get on your feet and maybe block
it a little bit block it but they're
gonna be changing the script the best so
so there may not be any point so I'll
tell you what thanks for coming in at
10:30 it's it's 11:00
maybe 11:05 go ahead and have some
breakfast or we'll see you later that
was my day then you come back in nine of
civilized hour maybe 9:30 yeah on
Tuesday and now we're gonna we got the
new script now we're gonna just do some
blocking we're gonna be joking and
laughing when I say blocking they're
just getting the cameras right you're
gonna stepping and doing so maybe I'll
come in this way yeah do that and then
you come in there we're gonna do ha ha
ha and then okay good let's uh let's
let's break for lunch good and maybe
we'll just go home and then a Wednesday
I think that the best gig is a game show
host
oh yeah we get but you shoot an entire
season in a week or we can have that
would be ideal run for a season but you
get paid for all those toys I'd rather
die but it's true I couldn't yeah
dying think there's only you can name
the sitcom's on one hand like actual
like three camera
there's single-camera comedy shows but
not a live audience laughing you know
that's that doesn't exist too much
anymore your honor the only the only
ones left but also back in the day when
you got started in a rep no no it's back
in the day when you guys when you guys
were doing sitcom stuff like that and
there were all those sitcoms WB and ABC
ABC sub yes yeah there was somebody no
well that was it right and that was it
right that was all there is but now if
you're a creative dude and CBS NBC TBS
all go nope nope nope you go alright
when we get my [ __ ] together and get my
creative friends together and post this
on youtube right and create all these
now that's the first thing people are
doing you got an F yes changing so much
right NetFlow exactly or Netflix or your
Netflix is changing every I got a friend
who has five shows on Netflix you
YouTube I'd say YouTube's the factory
yeah it's it's you know this is because
you need so much Netflix you still have
to get cleared by some header right
right where YouTube let's start a TV
show that we want to upload digitally
yeah get a fan base rollin you can do
that well it's like the best and the
worst like you look on YouTube and go
much [ __ ] out there but once in a while
there's a little diamond in the rough
that you'll find out like riff raff for
instance found them on YouTube he was
that diamond in the rough it's like nine
times out of ten more more 99 of 100
you're not gonna they connect what they
call the cult of the amateur is that
what it is nothing but right right right
you can recognize something in there you
ever hear the guy Andrew Kane wrote a
book about this called a coup Andrew
Andrew Andrew Cunanan Andrew keen right
you gotta listen to me you're not listed
on an hour but Andrew Kane
it had a great metaphor you ever hear
the infinite monkeys metaphor No so
there's a mathematical principle where
if you had an infinite number of they
could write a script hang an array a
script you know okay just by accident
because they didn't law of numbers with
right got it and he's like and on
YouTube you can find the riff raff okay
got it right right got it true fair
enough I know there's a there oh yeah
I'm like I said YouTube's getting bad
there's a reason why it's so hard to get
TV shows there's a reason why it's hard
to get on
or TV or even to get a big-time digital
show or a big-time YouTube Revd show or
you know there's a reason why it's
arrived oh it's okay sorry it should be
um this is just remember you can you to
hold your arm up oh my god your kids
teacher I'd be like this that was you
saying that the teacher I really care
about all I see is reach all I see is
real all right right you're just a fight
or you just can't something what do you
think about my reach overall I'm very
happy yeah I think I just need to learn
how to throw a punch and I'd be able to
use these I would tell you what I'm
teaching I need to learn stuff let's
come down here to turn that I trained a
little I had ten goofs shout out to Nick
goose in his dad trained me a few times
so I got to learn some fundamentals he
was really teaching me it's about these
two knuckles right here and about
turning that wrist over and pulling me
you see that and then so it's put the
cigarette out with the back foot answer
the phone
cigarette out shake it out answer the
cigarette out I don't play dude I will
seriously in one foul swoop
double kick your teeth that I can tell
them so I should I have Invisalign yeah
I won't do it yeah just met you guys but
I feel that where were we talking about
oh you're the toughest thing I've ever
done killed a pig with my bare hands
yeah I wanted to talk about in Hawaii
boar hunting can we and I just want to
get that other way so the audience out
there beats up people in Australia kills
it's like or I bet we could do with a
sorry let's French with a knife was
Japanese good with a knife so can I tell
you the quick cliffnotes please might
see my points of gin I don't mind then
what else you got right so I'm in Hawaii
tropical paradise on the island of Kauai
and my friends are local one of my
friends husband is a hunter yes takes me
out one day is like you want to go boar
hunting guy I'm like yeah I mean let's
go I got to experience that once in my
life so we go out with the bad boys with
the trucks the dogs with the GPS collar
guns knives everything I'm out there
with a knife and a book Crocodile Dundee
[ __ ] and I were out there and they want
me to get the kill because they want to
live through the haole the white boy
they wanted me to get the kill right how
these the white man they call out
how late how late nomads I'm the Holly
but I'm with the local bad boy so I'm
all good so we go out to the [ __ ]
jungle iins what's that so these are
some Cowboys they live out on the land
they [ __ ] kill there you know
spearfishing ologist anyway we get out
there and one of the big [ __ ] boys I
hear I hear him go get in here bad I
[ __ ] run in and he's holding the boy
it's a sow a female boar
it's a 130 pounds Sal he's always
holding it down with his foot and the
thing has these tusks and it's snarling
and the dogs are holding each limbs of
four dogs are holding down each limb and
they taught me before where you stab it
is in the back of the rib cage through
the ribs into the heart is not a humane
way to kill her so the first stab I'm
shaking humane way after the dogs are
you just I'm just doing what I was told
so I go for the step but I'm shaking
from adrenaline I mean if this is
intense [ __ ] sure I stab and I hit bone
and it makes this noise that to this day
my Jewish guilt meter went through the
roof oh you try again right
not very kosher dude I got it in on a
second hit yeah and I just felt this hot
air just really like a queef of love
real and the thing just folded you took
its life in experienced lion to your
body yeah exactly and then did you get
it right I got it right there and they
got you gotta eat in the heart Rada I
ate the heart oh they go we just get em
right that's my racist Hawaiian
invitation so it's red I spit it out you
know it's like still beating practically
I could still taste the iron and I spit
it out into this day when I go back
there like that's the how did I date the
heart batter that craziest [ __ ]
Australian Hawaii you're a pig heart
eater yep and you'll take take a [ __ ]
and I know when I came only national is
you about us I know that's national
title but it's like dominoes right so my
point is I wanted to come here and
impress you guys with some tales of you
know you already [ __ ] up okay good
good did you don't that bull check this
out this was the egalitarian feeling
that I
wasn't born this hour oh yeah the I felt
the the only word I can describe it was
maybe the best feeling was to feed a
neighborhood of children women and
everyone came around and they're all
eating with everything with my Pig that
and we take it back and they they know
how to cut the meat off we had a big
walker ginger soy and we're eating from
three hours ago my kill and feeding all
the kids start coming around eating and
I'm feeding everyone from my kill
I'm the egalitarian King I'm the one
who's shared and it was the feeling more
Deol it was so it was so hunter-gatherer
and then because we're so disconnected
from our meat and our hunt and
everything and then the next day I got a
coffee enema so I went from man to [ __ ]
in twelve that my friend was the hunters
mom I mean if all that none no I just I
was I'm all about weird experiences so
she was like my friend's mom was like do
you want to do a coffee and am I do that
why I don't know I want to try it I want
to know by judge me quite a few but no
I'm down I like coffee more than anyone
so if I stick it up my ass I mean if I
figure out why okay I think it's there's
you don't need to it's quite a lot of
there's a lot of health benefits of the
coffee enema one of them I think it
activates and gets that [ __ ] going down
there and coffee rocks yeah you
definitely get high because it's a
suppository buzzing as you know in the
console I screwed I would I just grind
up my old French Roast and sticking up
the old there's just a whole way to do
it I could you'd want to go to a place
they do them here I think to anyway I
think Janet Jackson calling me anything
get in your ass so I just get like a
like a like one of those bong rip things
and put them on this there's a whole
thing you would have someone do it you
don't know I have a kit I'll come over
there right I'll supervise any case for
the comment from covered in blood savage
hunter like your ass she folded me up
like a little baby on the bathroom and
[ __ ] my legs up and she's just you guys
see there's health benefits to it yeah I
think there's a lot well you know men
have you ever had a massage yes because
you're a good-looking kid if you ever
had a massage and then and hooked up
with the gal that's massaging you know I
don't think I ever have done that one
but I don't know about a happy ending no
shady play just saying I'm just I start
talking to a girl and then I think they
need to restructure the whole happy
ending thing and make them happy
beginning
hear me out hear me out hear me out
there's ink to hear so the whole time
all you thinking about is either what's
gonna happen are they gonna offer me a
head what's going on oh so the whole
time here now you can't relax so if they
give you a [ __ ] at the top then you
get to enjoy a 30-minute whatever you
decide to do afterwards when you're so
relaxed happy beginnings I swear who do
happy what's gonna go on she's kind of
close to my [ __ ] [ __ ] really usually
that's the signs back I asked you guys
you guys seem to be athletic in touch
human men can I ask you guys a question
favor eight inches I noticed it the
other day my friend my friends were
filming at the beach and I watched a
clip of us and I noticed I had the
question mark posture that's fine well
here's what I'd say it's called a
posterior yes posterior now watch watch
this see so what do you got here I you
have a great body
it's an apple bottom that's me that's me
me that's me I see what you did and it's
gonna be impossible to focus on all of
that
right okay now you take the glutes right
correct right and also sleeping I can't
sleep on my back but I they said to put
the pillow under the knee so you get the
flattened out you know your core sort of
flattened put the power if you're on
your stomach you put one under your
stomach action dudes I don't mean to
switch it up trouble sleeping like four
I never have eight thousand coffees a
day but go ahead no not anymore thrown
up so chill out on okay but I could I
someone sent me some CBD non like who
chooses Janek right a psychoactive non
psychoactive CBD how kind of thing that
you can put under your
and it said helps with sleep anxiety so
I'll [ __ ] give it a go I need this
way work well okay good I was but you're
not a pothead right no okay that's
probably why traffic Oh out it but but I
wasn't like we were you eating before
you went to bed no hey Doc I got this no
it's none of that
why do you think it happened though
Express yeah it's not not a diner so let
me try it let me apply what you just
talked one foot in well don't don't spaz
out hold on it's not even it's not
talking about breathing yeah it's not
realistic now just just tell us a little
bit I think you're fine I okay I don't
see that you have a swayback okay okay I
don't see that I'm gonna I could not get
you a performance do it I'm happy is
that we begin yeah right I'm not gonna
take a belt here for no reason perfect I
love that I need to be I need some you
know that Jordan Peterson structure in
my life you know it means slappy slow
yeah so yeah so anyway like I be I'm I
killed a pig with my sow in my bare
hands and fed the village of people that
was amazing have you guys ever hunted
and killed and I have hunted you go on
this trip I've done that with Rogan
several times how does it feel good
right now hunting is he yeah I've never
heard of nothing quite as in who I've
never fed a he an archery so I'm never
right but he oh I just don't know like I
mean I don't have time to because you
don't kill Archer well that's not a gift
for Bryan
that's a terrible gift I I don't have
time to arch I can I can do a shameless
plug I'm owners of my of a rolling paper
company cuz I know you guys aren't pot
heads but I'm sure you have a fanbase of
stoners out there so I just wanted to
leave these on the table because you
have a beautiful table of stuff this is
my rolling paper company called white
boys a self-explanatory
didn't know that's the slang on the East
Coast for papers they're called white
boys so buddy mine patented the name and
we became the partners on this and they
are organic no chemicals and that you
can find them pretty much nowhere but I
just wanted to play
Oh nowhere yeah they're really not
available rolling pin yeah no use those
know exactly but I just figured I'd
throw it out there cuz why not we're
here it's great so that's on the promo
in current events check now this is our
viewers oh yeah news yeah let's get into
some current [ __ ] will you guys watch
this riff raff thing or just go to the
club yeah let me see it which one is
this
[Music]
I assume this is where you this is
frenzy love stupid [ __ ] he's gay
I mean did I don't I witnessed news
[Laughter]
fearless that's as good as SNL but like
he's [ __ ] he could be on s it like
he's [ __ ] fearless he's smart
yeah he's he's he's up smart people just
think he's some dumb dude rap no no dude
the guy knows exactly what he's doing
it's first one Kanye West's hey what is
that
no wait what's it was it today some
difference it was so he did he did a
two-hour long sit-down interview with
Charlemagne where they went over
everything because Charlemagne the god
yeah don't mean the God who I like and
then the the showing that God interview
was whatever it's Kanye and he kind of
goes into everything that he's dealing
with and how he went crazy and all that
stuff but then he goes on TMZ he's
actually on TMZ right he was on teams
eat know he freaks out on TMZ and he
goes he and this the reason why I'm were
in the easiest today one of the reasons
he goes you y'all the reason why I got
lipo i addicted opiates I got lipo
because y'all kids at fuse is like yoga
your guys made fun of my brother-in-law
because he's fat so I got self-conscious
for my wedding I got lipo I addicted
opiates
I don't know everyone's like what the
[ __ ] and then he keeps going off and
goes yeah he says slavery was a choice
you know slavery is a choice and so
everyone's freaking out and one of the
producers at TMZ start going arguing
with him they got into it right Tonya
apologized to him like dude you yell and
we look [ __ ] do you think this is real
is this all because so cuz we're seeing
or talking about it he does have an
album coming out right favors choice in
your mind or see this is this is a
touchy subject but then he goes on
Twitter to say this elos I'm not saying
back in the day our ancestors chose to
get on that boat and be shackled what
I'm saying is slavery's a choice now in
the black culture my right you can get
yourself out of that I always say one of
my favorite books is black rednecks and
white liberals by Thomas saw a black
scholar it is a mind-blowing
and he's I think what Connie is saying
Allah people like Kanye and a lot of
people liked another woman who the red
pill the black woman there's a there's a
growing movement in the black in the
black community that are embracing a
conservative way of thought the idea
that this is up to us that we have to
look internally at our cultural habits
in the ghetto and things like that to
get ourselves out and and take a look at
ethnic minorities middleman minorities
like you know different groups that have
done so
West Indian blacks African blacks who
come in this country have a very similar
immigration experience as too many other
groups was a socio-economic issue so she
grew up in Chicago right and he's taking
on the South saying yeah so Kanye's seen
a lot of self-defeating behavior listen
what he says he goes to make myself
clear of course I know that slaves did
not get shackled and put on the boat by
free will
my point is for us to have stayed in
that position even though the numbers
were on our side means that we're
mentally enslaved the reason why I
brought up the 400 years point is
because we can't be mentally in prison
for another 400 years we need free
thought now even the statement was an
example a free thought it was just an
idea they cut out our tongues so we
couldn't communicate to each other I
will not allow my and so Tanya versus
the media's modern-day and by the way
guys nowadays especially if you're black
and a lot of black people complain about
this you have to be a liberal and
democratic or a lotta more going it this
hasn't worked for us in 40 years or 60
years they you know Thomas soul does an
amazing job of looking at black incomes
and how families were together until the
60s and he makes a very interesting case
I don't know all the numbers but it's a
great book love being interested I'm
black from the waist up you are I know
you are but but for the most part I
appreciate what Kanye West is trying to
do he's saying something's broken right
and I'm trying to address it in and it's
never politically correct cuz it's way
easier to say wait we're all victims and
we have somebody to blame
Kanye is saying that's not the way to go
okay what he's saying is that this is in
our own you a lot of these things can
happen in your own brain you can solve
these problems you can get down with
that
we're gonna said radical economic
transformation doesn't start out there
it starts in your mind huh and he said
you've seen some crazy [ __ ] for sure
them thing was hilarious right and that
whole thing was mom it's obviously an
issue I really like his mom passed away
from the surgery and all that if you you
wonder if opiate that's what he said he
no but he's also a thinker and he's
presenting new ideas Thomas saw read
Thomas saw okay [ __ ] I'm gonna write
I'll forget so I could write a black
rednecks and and white liberals okay
good let me say some crazy [ __ ] but a
lot of it is good okay so that's the
Kanye news as of this the guts man I
think Kanye's got guts in the right
place I think his hearts in the right
place in the south side of Chicago and I
think he saw that there are a lot of
things going on in the south of Chicago
that were work self evolved problems
they were not problems from God look I
was a history major you can pick up a
history book and know that being black
in this country was not easy and there
was a constant a sort of assault on
unjust resources and you just didn't
have listened to we can go on right
right no doubt but the bottom line is
that you if you begin to look at
yourself as a victim you're looking for
somebody to blame that's a positive so
much though that applies that doesn't
get you out of things the Jews I'll just
give me a really quick I just want to
just think about this for a second about
the Jews that no not note the Jews in
the first part of the 20th century in
after 1945 six million had been
systematically slaughtered gassed
starved worked to death okay we know
that it's called the Holocaust there had
been many different pogroms before that
for about a thousand years especially in
Russia and things like that in Poland I
think this is the number there are three
to four million Jews by the end of World
War two in a period of five years there
were 50,000 left ready so that's a
catastrophe right they made up less than
0.2% let me say it again
they made up less than 0.2% of the
population of the world okay
now ready they didn't have a homeland so
they kind of try to start settling in
Israel we know how that went
in the latter part of the 20th century
the latter 50 years after that
catastrophe one third of all Nobel Prize
was that's one-third Jews and blacks
officially comes to America there is
usual out to own property and business
not all eyes weren't not always and they
were before but our differences there
are a hundred differences I'm not trying
to make there are difference in all
middle men minorities but there are a
lot of examples and Thomas oil draws
this distinction where there are a lot
of examples of middlemen Linares RDF
ethnic Chinese for example again they
were allowed to own land and property
well not last not really actually a
world feeling ahead of blacks though
well well that's not the only reason and
that's that's all I'm saying so I think
Kanye West is trying to open the door
calm I agree I agree with you behave
always opening the door doors open it's
yeah it's long overdue and and you know
it's time it's time to start using
everybody for what they're pretending
yes
I wonder if drugs are part of all this
or if this is strategically he's sober
now
oh is it yeah he got off the drugs okay
he's sober sober like nothing doesn't
why don't be so description muds but
then they're [ __ ] dis off the problem
he's not taking enough people say I'm
sober but they're still taking it just
because their doctor gave me a drug
issues yeah I ran out of someone yeah
yeah I smoked weed forever and I know I
not nearly as much as I used to I used
to have to be stoned to come to a
podcast or get on the airplane now I
can't get stoned to get on an airplane
or do a podcast I pick my battles a
little more wisely maybe end of the
night little nightcap a little weed here
and there
whereas before I was just full conce Bob
Marley but now pump the brakes on that
it was never much of a drinker i-i-i i
can't drink too much the weed was always
my vice about pills i had an issue with
those before in the past those got may
had some laser tattoo removal done and i
got it I remember feeling I like a grab
me but I was luckily I was strong enough
to clip it in the bud but I felt oh [ __ ]
this except I could see how that could
do that to someone you know wasn't that
strong it was just like vicodins what
was your life but I [ __ ] do those
things all grass yeah and it's all the
same [ __ ] any other opioids just every
oh yeah it's [ __ ] gnarly epidemic so
I hurts yeah it's all the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
you out yeah it's too easy to pop those
[ __ ] things but luckily I got out of
there
riff-raff drinks that scissor bright
yeah man I tried it before you just
sleep it's just an officer up and you
just knock out it's not that far very
expensive other rappers and codeine
codeine drinking you mix it with soda
and it like this should be social drugs
I'd be great for your stomach yeah I
mean soda is so good for you people die
for you I don't even put a jolly rancher
in it it's like a whole technique like
you put the they call it lean but it's
actually codeine syrup and you pour it
in a certain soda drinks and you put a
Jolly Rancher and then roll it and it
dilutes perfectly to this syrup I've
seen my boys do it it's a whole science
yeah and then you just fall asleep I'm
like like if some guy in Houston came in
like using some get his knee at DJ he's
like the originator of bed everyone
wants his like his [ __ ] yeah kind of all
the cast is the high-end one and but
that that codeine that's in that so
expensive
yeah it's $700 for a bottle $100 for a
bottle is big yeah yeah that's it but
it's you know yeah is it that kind of a
bottle you look at $1,000 crazy yeah
it's crazy man what else world the sick
[ __ ] world this is a lighter one have
you seen this I saw this a dolphin
actually hits a guy there's an effort of
the dolphin to do that don't this looks
like I mean I'll let you watch first
quick check I thought I was going for
like the friendly tap
UCSB no so this guy's paddle boarding
onto the surf and some dolphins are
heading towards him and one dolphin what
he's doing I feel like dolphins like why
don't first in his [ __ ] board
Shumpert on me before hang time jumped
over the board yeah he was doing he
didn't know the guy was on top of that
just got shoulder check and then I have
a 20 it looks like you did it on purpose
I think you did a real no look at the
stopwatch but no
avoid the board yeah no it's a female
you can tell by the dorsal fin it's
eight inches no way look at that a quick
dolphin story if you don't mind this is
the only natural and habitat for them to
swim with humans is in Florida near the
keys I went with my girlfriend and we
went down there to swim with the
dolphins and they come in from the bay
and then they swim with you and they go
back out to their natural environment so
they're happy dolphins they're not
sitting in the Hilton Hotel getting
whipped by a baja Manian warlord turns
me on
let me to improve us so i'm swim with
the dolphins and there's this very drunk
german guy in our you know you go with a
group of people so this is very drunk
german guys being rude to everybody to
meet at gravity one has being a total
dick when he gets in the water the
dolphins felt his dick energy and they
can't poke in him really oh god what the
[ __ ] and to jump out of the water he was
laughing and then they put a handicapped
kid in the water and all the dolphins
came and started circling the
handicapped kid and making him laugh I
was like dude they're magical a little
creature so you know yeah that thing not
the way you Frankie give all those
shoulder you know yeah you're in my hood
yeah yeah I stopped harpooning dolphin
yes stop yeah that's just an S so [ __ ]
up even one by two nine watchin that
sushi place yeah you weren't here humph
you were here humph no way amazing yeah
help was an amazing sushi place and when
you'd go there like Fabrizia on those
guys they would bring out a sea turtle
which is actually legal Oh cut his
throat in LA huh
in LA oh yeah right by the airport
already so they had all the exotic so
people that were the Japanese that
really liked the exotic right over there
right so you get a turtle you get a sea
turtle they here they have live it's
crazy and you drink their blood would
you save this they have all kinds of
[ __ ] you'd have a lobster walking with
this shell open but it was still alive
either way it was for the authentic
brutal killer and sushi person right but
they got shot down doubt that they were
serving well that's that original have
you read some legend that's all friend
oh no he's Korean yeah I know I'm just
saying but they'd be weird should to
know the most how it happens those those
life I would eat the lifestyle cheapest
but
was raw but not you ever seen the live
movie with the UNAM it's like sticky
other alien Japanese the Norwegians they
all have whales remember that's how we
used to light our houses with well yeah
well that's what and then it became then
it became then it became rock oil rights
and that fossil fuel yeah mm-hmm
originally that's why the others those
those mostly Wharf those of big fishing
expedition back in the day that's all
for whale oil right mostly for the most
part yeah [ __ ] whale world was
running on whale oil what a trip and
that was before I only grew where yeah
what else we have to man what the [ __ ]
house is the only giant rotating mud
ball we call her Oh what's this it's a
guy who owns a little South African
safari park and his lion attacked him
while he was checking the cage well just
me the line doing line [ __ ] yeah this is
a killer [ __ ] oh no he's fine he's in
the hospital recovering just smiling in
the pit lion got sent a ball zone we can
put 20 pound cat yeah a ranger told him
that there's a weird smell coming from
the enclosure so he wants to go
investigate it was it lying piss fear in
part a bit yeah it smells like lime also
you know that the lion can kill you so
quickly but in this case he's probably
just going oh you're a dick so I team
inside the guide named hunter oh that's
the Ranger outside so this guy the owner
starts walking in damn that's a big ass
line aside well don't go into his
territory who do you think you are
exactly he's walking in right now oh
[ __ ] oh my buddy said hold up check how
fast - and so you got him by the neck
and just drags on
why did he do that he's a merit they're
Americans but he keeps going on they
sound American he's British Oh British
yeah so what happen they shot the ones
the line died unfortunately oh because
they had to protect the guy you have to
do that order this guy I know trains
lions and tigers and all the cats all my
lions are Lions are highly intelligent
because they are they are the kind of
animals that essentially are social in
their pride and so they they're very
moody and if you don't read their mood
you're in big trouble may I see the
girls up there the girls don't click on
that that's big oh that's click so he's
he owns the ark that part yeah and he
went into the Lions domain lion does
lion [ __ ] and they kill the line you got
out you kind of have to though you have
to protect you should steal a [ __ ]
key yeah there was a dumb move though I
don't know why I guess I'm carrying a
grown man dragging a grown man that run
yeah did you see that me and that
honestly I've been to South Africa to us
those safaris or those parks and one of
those incredible things I've ever seen
is there was just a hillside full of
lions and you ride up and then they
start making these he's a really low and
they're rumbling and then all of a
sudden you look up and you see like
seven lions are they want it's in their
wildest there in the wild well I mean
maybe overall city huge enclosed area
but it's you're looking around and
you're just in the bus and you just
seeing all these lines and and you feel
the vibration almost like we had a
concert and the base is low and you feel
the but imagine these lines in unison
growling the power that you felt so in
the food chain dude like you're just
like oh [ __ ] like there and they were
just rumbling they're just in the
rumbling just looking at you like
spraying look in their little leg up one
of those doors Lions will I mean like
you can tell if that line really wanted
him that time I was like hey cut the
[ __ ] yeah he was playing with them
like cats play and doesn't let go I
won't be the worst animal you'd have a
tab like what would the last animal
you'd want in this room Tiger Tiger
Tiger size of tigers terrifying okay
what what that's it so tiger
well I think you died pretty quickly
well maybe in the water will grow up a
gorilla would be down for Ella no
problem really I feel like you could
look at a gorilla and kind of reason
with it you could look at and be like
dude what closer on the evolutionary
buh-buh-bear a polar bear you're gonna
die if you're in the case of the polar
bear you're gonna die smile see my polar
bear and it's not gonna be course and a
grizzly he's gonna eat you
well grizzly should that to hibernate
there's a lot of elements dude no I'm
saying if you're gonna die by something
like if we put a grill in him he wants
to kill you you just grab your head oh
yeah dude try to pick have you ever
tried to pick up a house cat that
doesn't want to be picking up a cat dude
you're ain't gonna pick up a house cat
what do you think you're gonna do - the
question is what kills you faster I
would say the the lion or Tori I like
cats because they grab you by the neck
by the neck and so you you're done it's
done yet whites no pump air you want to
go quit did you guys hear about that a
great wife just bites the [ __ ] out of
you and you bleed to death yeah a crop
though I feel like a croc as terrifying
as it is I'm gonna let for a little bit
and it drowns you which is terrifying
mmm before you get them all yeah you
breathe know what's snapping down
crushing your bones you're not feeling
that being eaten alive in here did you
hear about that kid this was in the news
last week a kid the chances are one in
six trillion or something
22 year-old kid got attacked by a bear
bit by a rattlesnake and bit by a shark
within four years
sounds like a good it's real look it up
is he alive yes he's alive and they said
the chances are one in four trillion
some crazy number mapping they said the
chance of you getting bitten by a snake
or one in Manila by a bear and look up
sounds like he sucks at life man shark
bear snake in less than four years
that's impressive wonderful quite in
where he shouldn't be where he shouldn't
be I don't want to be this kid's friend
oh he's from Colorado Horace just 20
years old
Dylan will already been bitten by a
shark
nicknames lucky yeah in Hawaii that run
in leaving him with several stitch
in his leg last year he had to get nine
staples in his head Jesus after a bear
invaded his camp site and as for that
rattlesnake well that happened three
years ago while he was visiting Utah
Dylan is doing fine and take let's try
doing sucked up being in the wild a
parent goes looking for John's tasty
these tastes good to say he's got
something it's office since I stopped
wearing barbecue sauces cologne yeah
it's full mouth I mean jeez anyway
that's really right that's really look
at that I mean you didn't get attacked
by a great white no it was it was
probably was in Kauai actually got in
Hawaii yeah oh look at his header here
Jesus if you've never heard of a botfly
up bak flies the larva that's only in a
couple of countries that plants in you
and yes look up YouTube videos where
they squeeze it out in the mag in this
big shot like my buddy had it
he had headaches really bad for like a
year migraines he couldn't figure out
wife's a doctor the family's doctors
they couldn't figure out finally like
where have you been unless they put it
together that he was in a Central
American country which I can't remember
right now and I guess it's only there in
a couple places he was camping he got
botfly and his wife he showed me the
footage his wife popped his head see a
botfly didn't bring that up first and
the thing flew out and hit the cameras
oh wow maggot this big that was digging
into his brain for a year Wow a bot a
bot bo TK look kind of cute it's bro but
this guy when it's done but that but
it's the larva of that it there does he
like that okay so it's common to Bob fly
it's the nastiest [ __ ] thing yet what
happened to homeboys brain though he's
all right now yeah he's that botfly
removal the top one yeah it's [ __ ] do
it
insects huge no do the other one police
it's all in that's where its beliefs oh
this is cop and people don't know that's
your boy no no but it looks just like
that
where's that I don't get what we're
looking at look at this the things we're
going out of his head dude I don't see
it is so gross oh it's coming out dude
we're you don't see that little [ __ ]
thing right there right there
holy [ __ ] so you got the Oh Vonda key is
that the son of a [ __ ] oh you don't
seize it out yeah I think it's when you
put milk to get it's 40 minutes long
I'll keep going just fast forward it see
that [ __ ] me up more than any of this
look at the size Oh God Oh gross well
that's a giant pop fly back that's just
the larvae well it's it's disturbing how
dare you put that in the mic you like
gothic yeah right no but imagine it was
in a keep growing but he didn't know it
was growing in his head for a year
well he's doc did he get it out it
wouldn't believe the other executive and
he was camping and believing it's like
where it happened I'll check that house
kill yeah what else is going on this
world this one I thought was funny cuz
brain you were talking about this guy
Josh Rosen yeah who's that you better
explain this he was in the draft he got
Josh Rosen was a he's the quarterback
UCL he got drafted eighth overall first
round you say his father's a1 the top
like brain surgeon the hog world
his mother graduated from Harvard so
he's not CEO okay he's not hurting for
money sure he's fine they have some
thought he was the smartest quarterback
in the draft and he got drafted eight
and the he on the mic and they go what
to feel like to be drafting us seven
teams made a mistake not picking me a
chip on my shoulder and and I like for a
reason you don't mean I like everyone I
just don't I don't like the kid for the
reason he just rubs me well yeah yeah
yeah I guess so what's this
what's his GM say-so the Browns vice
president he said that there's just
something about him he didn't like
that's why they didn't want to pick him
either
and it was due to this this meeting at
an airport with the UCLA volleyball team
so he goes I was at an airport he said
you see all these volleyball team was in
front of me you heard so much about
Rosalyn he's this or he's that
we know how people talk so I asked the
volleyball Coaches what's Rosen like he
said you should probably ask his
girlfriend she's the one she's one of
the players she's over there I'm like
all right coach that's good enough I
don't know what did it I don't know what
this all means but there's something
about him that ball
me so he has this thing where people
just talk for some reason if you ever
and that should happen I don't like
someone they won't hire you based on
you'd be not a likable person and then
he you know he's like oh I'm like Aaron
Rodgers and Nimrod resists water in
Rogers shaft and he actually played
really well he got embarrassed and he's
trying to like relate to to him and I
don't know what it is I was like I
[ __ ] that guy man usually a male [ __ ]
that guy weird can we switch go sorry I
don't own the day right are you familiar
with the book walking just kidding
movies waking yeah so in the book here's
a website just so much just thought of
that was a you don't suck New York Times
bestseller is it really yeah good I
bought it Times bestseller um oh yeah
his open relationship status that's a
tricky one man I you know I I don't know
if I could pull that off I make one so
can you know what I mean that's it young
must type of cat dude right my buddy my
I got a couple my friends would pull it
off and I just don't know if I that's
better way to look at it is to say I'm
never gonna try to control your behavior
and I'm never gonna tell you what to do
that I guess you go there and I go over
here ultimately you want to see if you
keep coming back to that ain't right I
understand that I understand I I think
it's I I don't know how that movie ends
for them right I live for abri it's
great right he's not he's not normal
that dude's an alien hi robbery it's
great and I think I'd be a supposed to
type of personality to deal with it
before like Whitney I feel like it's
tough around the girls
I feel like for if you're Whitney
because there's you want a family and
kids right normal life but you're an
open relationship I don't know if that
worked
did you read that book what did my I
don't [ __ ] know did you read that
book the truth and uncomfortable book
about relationships he wrote the same he
yeah that's about am I what's that
whose chat comes no no no different
person it's called the truth and
uncomfortable book about is he also
wrote the book
about the game it was called well in the
books front truth and uncomfortable he
explored that world of open and you know
it's funny what's he said well he came
back after living that life and living
with three girls and having a total
polyamorous relationship he was I dude
it sounds awesome but then when the
reality comes about to having to make
all these different women happy with a
different person than the clashing of
he's like it's [ __ ] exotic one
girlfriend could be a lot of work
imagine three so he came back at the end
of the book but maybe I shouldn't ruin
it spoiler a writer he's a very good
yeah very good book I was fascinated
with that [ __ ]
this book is sort of the resolve of that
life he led and and then I don't want to
ruin the book but at the end he he comes
full circle he comes and realizing was
in for him or yeah it's pretty much I
don't want to say too much but the books
great just about the site like basically
you know he breaks down the psychology
of what women the oddly are drawn to
yeah and you can you can dress in a
certain way you can speak in a certain
way you can approach a woman in a
certain way where your your chances of
getting the results you want which is
her interest or higher than otherwise
and this is coming from from his
research yeah he actually he actually
what journalist yeah he's a journalist
he went and looked at he went talked to
these guys that actually run seminars on
this yeah yeah submerged in the culture
of girls it's nothing I like it's real
weird interesting though he's
interesting I don't like it either it's
creepy I have to say no problem if
you're someone I know yes I talked to
him about it he's a very small guy yeah
really littles little he's not a guy who
you think of as a ladies man and I
talked to myself with him at dinner one
time and I I said what got you to read
the book and he goes I was lonely I
didn't want to be left I didn't I didn't
like it he's very honest very good
sender wrote the book is use lonely so
did the rest again he wanted to and
that's what he looks like that he wasn't
oh my
good well I'm not reading the book how
to get girls from that see what he did
you see the difference look yeah let me
look yeah no right there is it
definitely no on the left yeah
difference right trust again the right
more than the difference like what he's
able to do he really went off he
transformed it's interesting he got
girls in human behavior one of the
things I remember taking from you tried
it actually tried this dude I actually
tried this one of the things is that
it's called an egg like you you you
you'd make a negative comment to a
beautiful woman yeah but but a nice
negative comment for instance you go to
there's three girls ones were a lot more
attractive than the other two you talk
to the other two women that aren't as
attractive and as soon as the beautiful
one says anything you say oh so you got
something right here anyway you know or
you make it well you get them insecure
no I weird little drug of three in the
hot ones like no you shut up [ __ ]
without me I thought he did this my
buddy I was with this guy and was
beautiful way just really sweet girl and
he goes got a wig hey guys what she's
nothing you go then he goes and he goes
like this he goes I ever read the game
it works like he was older I got dude I
go if you ever do that around making
somebody feel bad so I can get in their
pants yeah it's creepy you know I'm not
buying that he gets ladies oh you [ __ ]
wood now he's got a family and all that
she's just working it you're starting
out on a lie right I mean yeah it's
doing what's not you it's not right it's
not another original edition of Yahoo
it's it's a fake I think though there
are guys that teach like there are men
that freeze up around women right they
don't know what to do look at him and
yeah and these guys and the book can
help you with actually a smart guy and
he's not a bad guy no this is smart
shame the guy forget some ass okay Gabby
Reece Jimmy okay look aside have you
read the book I read the book I'm like a
day-and-a-half
very good book honestly I learned chin
when you actually do like it felt stupid
doing it but when you do it you start
like you noticing like it working little
things like I was at
I was at a club and there was this girls
talking I was so bored with the group
people I just read the book and I did a
couple of the things don't remember what
I did it works we really were he goes
your she had a boyfriend is that because
you're an amazing person she goes the
way you talk do if you want that same
girl and just have a normal conversation
that's the path works to some guys are
capable the Agila gear confident good
looking buff do that beats people up
your comp you've got you walk through
life with your chest out for Jordan
Peters and said it you're gonna take my
workshop okay we'd love that
oh yeah anyway sorry I didn't you shut
up when it comes to picking up girls
because you're right he walks in and we
call him hungry eyes yeah you but also
just be a normal human being I have
friends who feel like yeah I know I know
but no if I would lie to the girl off
the bat yeah but when you're in high
school and girls tell your grocer you
know there's a lot of damage that's done
yeah yeah no I hear you reverse see
blues you were the biggest stud in the
planet some guys never have even dated
girls on even look at their direction
not once
think about it lately him you know what
I mean he was play pick that before
pictures yeah yeah no [ __ ] yet probably
there well in the book you guys would be
what they call Naturals you guys already
have that thing about you but a lot of
these guys are like computer nerds they
don't know any but anything about how
that makes sense
they try to teach them those things and
they're lonely and mainly most out there
[ __ ] lonely your Facebook is doing a
dating site now no yeah that's good so
alright Facebook because they have all
that influence [ __ ] Facebook is actually
in the launch a dating site because
Facebook's used for her anyway
Zuckerberg said this is a yesterday at a
seminar when he announced this that one
in three relationships start online
tonight oh yeah one in three I believe
he goes we don't want to be just for
hookups anymore Luigi you know Instagram
Twitter all that just for hookups people
sign those DMS so
we're gonna kind of everyone's hooking
up anyways so now we're gonna create an
app dude it's okay man I'm married in 51
like this [ __ ] when I would yeah if I
had been if I was 30 and there was
tinder and all that [ __ ] dude I would be
on antibiotics
Oh guys are you guys glad that you had
the first roughly half of your life no
cell phones internet soil yeah you have
a reference but yeah I feel look looking
back like at least we had half a guide
say half of my life was without all that
[ __ ] so you actually people were
different oh I'll meet you at 3 o'clock
at the quiddity you had to be had there
was neither there's no people who had
different moral ethics it's that because
I never look at my phone oh yeah also if
you didn't grow up with cell phones and
Instagram and all that stuff in those
crazy video games I grew up on building
avatars variety of games right right now
old school develop more of like I feel
like your personality and a way to talk
and you figure things out and you were
my son's obsessed with Minecraft and
he's six and I have to like take it away
from yesterday he was like I go what are
you doing and he's like he's in his own
world like I am like so I'm like good
he's using his imagination right nothing
I'm good I'm fine I know what do you
guys I'm your business something bad Hey
so yeah that's what are you gonna do you
know it could be a long women in my yeah
so I hit him
we that we had we lucky we had I think
at least anyone like that I hate to just
refer to all Millennials but it's
different like you go get customer
service for some twenty oh then they
just seems so like kind of help us and
spoiled an entire this is weird I don't
know what it is there was no struggle or
something there's no but they don't
leave a lot of them don't out a volley
back and forth with conversation yet so
which social it'll be every time yeah
some how you doing it good it's like
yeah it doesn't yeah but you feel that
the you guys do this a lot the podcast
it's a basically like you said you put
the phone down for two hours you like
normally if I just met you guys like
this we wouldn't get this deep and get
to know each other for two hours last
time he talks its own for two ow
I loved actually getting talked to for
two hours so true yeah we're having we
have a real conversation yeah that's I
think it's a good I think it's good
practice in social behavior and just
overall just to get to know it like I
just met you guys today
right so no better way than a podcast to
sort of get to know someone and get in
you know I forget the cameras or arm of
intimacy actually I think that's why
podcasting is kind of leaping all these
other kind of you know entertainment
passing because you know all that
because I've been a late night show
finger car and you're listening to the
show right now you listen three dudes
talk you feel like you probably
conversation I feel like I knew you guys
already because I listened to the
podcast I'm familiar with you I saw
coming and I have an idea of I'm like
okay you're comfortable right away you
know what I mean because I I somewhat
had a pulse on your guy's vibe us I've
listened it's off your vibe you speak
the language right right like one of us
any lives in Venice how do I get in the
game what do I got a definition you guys
shoot you I mean if this suck is dick
well well well we get our hands on you
and we see when guffy up a little bit I
gotta take your piece in we got to see
what goes on you're not bummed me out is
I love Howard Stern right he's the
Godfather right the best when he's
hating on podcasting the other day and
it broke my heart was like oh really
because and I do this thing you might
not try knowledge well in the situation
I'll see pop gets a bit of a threat to
that so I was about to say it's 10 he
goes does anyone even make money doing
pot like how the [ __ ] would you make
money because why would you listen to
that and all the stuff and then the guy
goes yeah you know I broke and he brings
up Joey goes you know Rogan like man
those guys have big podcast man and the
Howard Stern goes but how do they I know
yours
Rhona make money off that pot make
comedy in TV he has no I was like
seriously you'd be one of us my man if
you didn't sell out hasn't made that
trend like it is basically a pod makes
500 million years
yeah he's doing just so he's like I
don't what he's doing just what yeah
yeah and off see podcast is a threat to
what he does because you have to pay to
listen to it right right and listen
right right tell me who we're the
followers you gonna go right let's get
Jim oh just the funny one from China cuz
you know China for whatever reason
Chinese people in airplanes there's
always little funny things that happen
like last time there's an old lady that
threw coins into the engine to wish it
good luck warming up what do you mean
yeah I was before the flight no go home
with a letter that he eats good luck
that's fun final so this guy got fine
eleven grand for trying to open he
didn't know he says he doesn't know that
this was a an exit door like a emergency
exit door until he opened it and then it
fell in words and then he freaked out
you know the reason why I did it was
already deep planing so he just felt
like charging eleven grand for being
immoral here's you all over again for
being [ __ ] stupid how about that she
may not have enough money if he's Tom
then that's yeah and then that latter
thing came out to that inflatable ladder
you're gonna work for this era comedians
I'd never done a bit about the fact that
Magic Johnson beat AIDS before he has
Johnson like a pony he has a magic [ __ ]
yeah Johnson's money beat things you
know I'm Magic Johnson god it's perfect
it's good you can I think it's probably
been done yeah as I say I'm a little
late I came up with that while ago it
gets late just one quick anime one about
Nate Diaz
so right Okamoto from ESPN said that
they're looking to have him return to
the AFC August yes that's the LA card
right are you team Diaz how can you not
like I like
I'm [ __ ] that live I'm a fan there's a
risk real as it gets
27 and his brother - Nick - is fighting
again right well Nick we don't know yet
but Nate will definitely that record
does not I mean 1911 you look at that
that [ __ ] man he's just what is
it about is it the heart is that the
cardio is that the craziness is a
combination look at his body and it's
not like he's some written that
[ __ ] is a zombie dude like he
doesn't stop as that was a track coach
is that word about something like the
new party or something there's something
marathons that yeah they're always grown
training with them all the time so I get
the inside stories I remember Nate told
me once - he's like yeah I actually
start training jiu-jitsu cuz the guy
would give me a burrito to train with
the bean burritos how he started to eat
caddy not like that bro it's not that
matter like Arthur's trying to stack
he's gonna fight a big big name who's it
gonna be Yahoo I'll tell you off here
but I have an idea okay what's going on
with Conor McGregor's is is he feel bad
about all this stuff does he's dizzy
aware and cognizant of his actions or is
he just sort of in this weird bubble
I don't meant to blinded get anybody's
glass name buddies I just meant to
create a big stir right to this hype for
the right and I think it worked you know
but it ruined that card I mean as a fan
that card he's here but all he cares
about is being the you know the face of
you see still and being the most talked
about man in the fight
is he gonna fight who's he gonna fight
well what do you know he won't lose that
one I think you'd lose that fights kind
of into the second fight was close and I
don't 55 I think Conor beats them yeah
which word is what they'd find out they
you have to wait to see what the New
York Commission because it's what New
York does suspension wise they can't do
anything but the fight for him and
they're gonna wait to be going through
Ramadan so you won't fight for you know
a few months so they're just waiting to
see what happens do khabib is the next
thing hi he's the next big thing I'm
sort of somewhere right now I would tell
you MMA enough what's the deal the champ
right now I know he won the belt and
he's the truth right he's be like he's
he's a special silat he does yeah he's
net he has not lost ever and
he never lost a ring grabs you your your
your at the end Ferguson that was gonna
be the fight what a fight you guys send
this to after his last fight if he
fought first and I would put my money on
first I think I would do it because I'm
a Ferguson is so elusive and good is it
look people compare me a lot they sort
of like you're a combination of Ferguson
meets khabib person you're like a gringo
Kendall Grove dude whatever you want to
call me I have a this like it's this
weird thing where it's a combination of
like oh he's a nice guy but he's gonna
slide in this upper hook that's so
unfamiliar yet foreign at the same time
domestic and I'm not talking aboot I'm
talking this is coming at you with so
much fervor and love that you won't fly
out of your shoes by the way tucked in
his hip how about he's so nice unless
you're not stray Leah you know that's
when I see your ass ow Hawaii so I think
I think we have resolved by the this
show that I'm not to be [ __ ] with no
no unless you're the minute not I would
never look at your fists look at like
when I start taking photos when I start
doing the like the the dear
yeah the Diaz the sort of looking down
you know start working on it yeah yeah I
need to work on my left hook this is
rice sign huh okay so I guess you're not
in a box no anymore thank you for coming
thank you for having me man well this
has been a disaster yes there's awful
thing ever thanks for wasting two hours
of my life Simon racks making it easy
for us on a Wednesday we love you man
this Friday Saturday I'm in Minnesota
House of comedy Minnesota get your
tickets Mall America and then June I'm
in Houston oh oh what's not gets
canceled have to shoot I'm sorry guys
he's got a camp let's not New York that
to cancel I am a reschedule I'm sorry
I'd love you you come out and see me
this Saturday still some tickets left
this Saturday a Colusa casino one show
only and I will be there hard and ready
and don't jump on stage and punch talent
in the dick no we wouldn't stop at all
please look at May 31st June 1 June 2008
in Minnesota copy this works it
shout-out to nick swardson can i plug my
voice on the show i have a show in LA
rolling papers yeah thank you very much
for that los angeles beer and music
festival may 12th at the at the Pershing
Square in downtown LA Pershing Square
may 12 6 p.m. to 10:00 p.m. I'll be
playing with alien ant farm Mickey
Avalon and to come on down and that
lights gonna be fun as always a lot of
this company that's doing this to have a
good time it sounds cool
yeah it'll be fun and and my Instagram
can I be that dude and just load out
there that's it simon rex for15 i just
need to get a couple more followers to
feel better about myself and your
YouTube channels good as well - yeah /
Dirt Nasty I believe oh come on babe
thank you guys thank you this is the
final kid yeah